foreign
[Music]
the CW show was good until in bran off a
cliff
and Ezra Miller is still at Large
but back in the 90s did you know the
flash was a dull Network TV show with
three straight to video movies what the
hell is this it's a loxin onion burrito
good though yeah
sure this version's bad but at least
it's not choking fans in Iceland bad
right did you want to fight
The Flash movies
Barry Allen is Torn Between Two Worlds
Cobb and nerd his whole family is cops
but he prefers being in a lab running
blood and semen through a database I
happen to like those test tubes
Everything Will Change when lightning
blasts him into his trusty open racks of
chemicals transforming Berry into the
flash a guy with the power to press fast
forward on himself
and on the background behind him leaving
Central City's criminals with nothing to
do but stand around like absolute losers
pretending to get punched
wow this sucks
the flash may have been blessed with
super speed but he's still God
at least six major weaknesses the
sleepies
[Music]
Barry what's wrong
are you okay
ah wipe down the slippies
[Music]
the munchies do you believe I'm still
hungry
you want this one no help yourself
oh I am starving no no I'm in trouble
even the kibble's starting to look good
bad gas
these gross tear gas into the station
and how are we gonna stop them
[Applause]
[Music]
forgetting to clean up
[Applause]
Tina
[Music]
even by Hero standards he's terrible at
keeping a secret identity no
I don't need to know yeah we gotta tell
the chief
coming up how did you get back here so
fast you're like on a couple of seconds
400 blocks of remote control
[Music]
I did there your shoes are on fire oh uh
yeah we'll drop the match on the rug but
I'll be there in a Flash
what are you doing here
while I was driving by and I heard the
alarm over his own behavior
but this Flash's real weakness is where
he sticks his lightning rod I can't
believe it was over so quickly it isn't
over yet is it watch Barry cycle through
a bevy of bachelorettes like Iris West
who wasn't a redhead like the comics
either but you didn't see anyone forget
about her Casting did you hmm Spot the
Difference Tina who works for Star Labs
by day and will they won't they
industries by Night wow
on TV I might as well look my best
you look terrific Megan the hard-boiled
repo girl turned Pi turned GoGo 90s
business lady Danny told you quit
bugging me hello yeah Paul I need to
speak with you hold on hello Don I'll
get back to you Dr Frost I've
feminist
I'll take that as a compliment you
sexist pig and Julio his partner at work
and partner in crime
before his eyes pop out of his head like
a couple of golf balls Jinx and I are
old news Jinx when I walked into that
club she was all over him like a cheap
suit the show was basically Seinfeld if
Jerry sometimes went for a run I'm gonna
break up with her Julio she's a slow
Walker
the real as the flash takes on Central
City's most notorious villains and ruins
their fiendish plots
Pike is a psycho who demands absolute
loyalty from his gang
but with a lair that cool sign me up
best gang Hideout since the Foot Clan
easily the ghost a nerd who lives Walt
Disney's dream of freezing himself so he
can wake up in a future where he
controls the media the flash will have
to deal with ghost ruthless crew of
really old people plus some teens who
are probably wondering why he hasn't
tried to molest them yet I could use a
couple of smart kids another way around
time someone showed you what Total video
really means
then there's the tricksterer Mark
Hamill's beta test for the Joker
[Music]
he'll brainwash The Flash into becoming
Ezra Miller
[Music]
and he would have gotten away with it
too if it wasn't for his sidekick prank
a girl who's dressed like a clown and
obsessed with a villain who treats her
like dirt and okay I think baldini owes
someone some money here this is clearly
the inspiration for Harley Quinn
for a show that's aiming for the Batman
89 cool Factor
[Music]
but settles for more of a Batman 66 vibe
made by the guys who would go on to make
The Rocketeer wear the rocket
in this insane hybrid of live-action
cartoon soap opera whatever happens
it's not going to get in the way of our
friendship and hatred for the literal
concept of television
[Music]
[Applause]
why do they hate TV sorry it's only TV
bad TV you said it show story
Alan Square Biz Magnum P.I this lab is
dead anyway man I'm getting too old for
this emphasis on Hamill Harley rough
draft.jpg does anyone care how I got
these scars head to the Future Law and
Order DCU 7 of 90s How the West Was done
gum shoes and Berry sucking at
one-liners I realize I'm an unhappy
childhood probably led you to all this
but that's really no excuse sorry
anyways shooting galleries closed
remember me it's over we need some air
out here something stinks and I'm at the
show ghost he always works for me don't
touch that dial The Case Closed
Nightshade it's not guns that kill
people it's he's alive
hahaha
the quick and the red
say what you will about this show but
they sure knew how to end a scene with a
bang you know I hate to kick a man when
he's doing a good job of it himself but
although this is your day off there's a
stack of test results they need your
signature swell
gotta go fast no way I can do this voice
they are not cool enough I prefer epic
actually
super power ninja turbo Neo Ultra Mega
extra Uber prefix combo any line from
Spider-Man across the spider verse